today we will be playing terrible
fortnite clones there's gonna be bugs
salty kids lag and lots more
it'll be a great video i think you guys
need to get a cool skin like me and carl
god mine's so cool brace yourselves it's
gonna be terrible
i've already spent 30 dollars on it i
actually kind of like it oh we're
falling
carl look i have a sword
oh i'm terri how did you guys get soared
because we paid money
me and chandler are just losers and tank
tops a channel has a hat though you
don't have a hat
i have three hats on at the same time
wait how does chandler have a sword
i bought it so everyone here bought
stuff except me lovely
oh is this fortnite look it's the battle
bus
it looks just like it oh my gosh this
fortnite map is so realistic
everybody press tab so you can look at
the map let's go to goose grove
all right boys we're dropping at goose
grove everyone count the people dropping
out of the bus
wait there's only 21 players and we're
four of them oh i jumped by accident
i go oh i'm on a carpet i'm on a carpet
i'm in a delorean oh you guys are above
me
noobs yeah you got to drop low although
i might have undershot mine
noobs look at this right on the building
and
right in the window i got a gun boys oh
god
i got three guns nice man that's
actually pretty cool um
how do i get materials oh i got a jump
pad
i'm gonna hit this duck oh other chest i
got another chest give me that
this duck has 5000 hp that means it's
got to go i'm coming
guys come help get the duck get the duck
carl i'm putting you in charge of
monitoring the zone yeah make sure we
don't die
yeah good luck with that we're doing
something important here
carl we're beating a
oh tesla cyber truck oh my gosh oh weird
that you guys aren't getting maps right
now uh who ain't boy i got 800 maps
guys so far i would say roblox fortnite
is better than normal fortnite i just
really like this game
like you guys are just agreeable simps
oh wow carl likes fortnite what a nerd
boys come with me let's go get some
kills i'm getting mats bro we need math
bro i'm still trying to figure out who
matt is we're literally facing a bunch
of five-year-olds how much mats do you
need
[Music]
oh i just got shot i just got shot help
where i'm in the tall building
just give up on them we don't leave a
squad member behind all right guys come
right here to me to me i'm inchworming
down the stairs
i'm gonna jump pad i'm coming in hot i'm
coming in hot
all right chandler are they in the
building no they sniped me from
somewhere
ah i found him i found him ah
they're shooting me oh i'm getting shot
oh they're hacking i flew into the air
and instantly got down with one shot
wait what happened to all my health
you got shot when did i get shot i'm
coming in hot
i'm jumping out the window yo carl this
game full of hackers is so much
fun bro how do i redeploy
how do i redeploy you press the spacebar
i did and i didn't fly i need help come
over to me
come over to me don't worry guys i'll
just watch this is why i love battle
royale
what how did i just die oh we're using a
campfire without telling me
i guess i'll just drink some coca-cola
all right i'll block the door well we
have to leave guys
the zone's ending carl you are in charge
of the zone
i'm telling you now we're gonna get shot
on the orange thing we have a jump pad
go to it yeah as soon as you hit that
jump pad you're gonna die watch
nope oh they're right above us in the
mountain
i got eliminated taylor you look like an
idiot
oh bro he's nice whoa yeah let's just
play against a bunch of five-year-olds
jimmy all right again again again we're
going again yeah we gotta run it back
let's catch a dub let's work together
and win here's the deal you might notice
carl has a face cam now and the reason
why i gave him one despite him not
actually winning a challenge is you guys
would not stop complaining in the
comments
good job guys i don't trust this game's
anti-cheat so every time i die it's by a
hacker oh wait how do i thank the bus
driver
you gotta hit w wait guys ready we're
going to jump right up go
go go oh my gosh holy cow man
i'm not going to make it so can you make
it to the castle oh no jimmy's not going
to make it
i'm going to go to the pyramid i call
chest echo chest i didn't want to hang
with the boys anyways yeah your boys
scrapped right now i got a scoped rifle
oh i found a legendary weapon i got a
thermal scope bro i'm about to
wreck some eight-year-olds day hold up
i've been waiting to ruin some
eight-year-old days
oh rocket launcher oh tactical shotgun
what noob left attack shot on the
ground oh my gosh chris look at my
screen
there's four chests right here yo dibs
on at least three of them make sure you
guys get shields if you find them
we may be roblox news but we're not four
night noobs how do i deploy my glider
someone uh southeast oh i'm coming from
the flank
oh yeah here we go you boys dropping in
in the water boys
i'm gonna snipe them it's a bush oh
somebody got knocked
oh ah there's so many people
everywhere there's people on the hill
bros
oh i got one i snapped one
where are they on the hill they're
everywhere bro oh they're from behind us
they're west oh there's more in the
water chris they're in the water i'm
dead
no i got ganged up by like three
separate teams
uh oh someone's right here
like get out of here kid oh drop them oh
no no
south south one's down one's down oh no
no carl's watching all of you die
carl come save me i'm trying the game
here
i got died look on the ground
oh you died by a bush wookie i killed
two people
i think everyone i don't got revived
chris yeah
carl yes chandler do you guys like this
fortnite ripoff
no no not really luckily i have another
one up my sleeve
let's switch
we are now playing streused which as you
can see is just like fortnite
but the problem with this game is you
can't join teams there's no squads
so chris and carl are actually on the
other team this is free-for-all so we're
all gonna be fighting each other
oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh i'm
terrified i'm terrified oh my gosh
how hard can you try kid
yeah why don't i just get double team
that's fun
oh i snuck up behind someone i snuck up
behind someone
oh you okay tenley oh my chance are you
living on fire
oh get screwed hey guys let's talk like
we're tifu
all right yeah we're cranking 90s here
since the only thing i know about
fortnite is that you crank 90s i'm
getting double-teamed i got two on me
right now
oh flamethrower dude i'm getting
freaking stream snipe
look at this kid trying to build 1v1 me
bro
you got to build cause you're bad you
gotta build cause you're bad kid
get sweat yeah bye
you had shields bro i had 20 health am i
at the top of the leaderboard i think so
all right i got on top of the lighthouse
let's have some fun
why are so many children going after me
bye
jailor there's three people shooting at
me and they're just ignoring you i don't
get it
hey yo jimmy hey jimmy hey jimmy hey
carl
what the freak hey chandler how are you
feeling chandler
why are you just literally camping in
the sky you freaking noob oh look at
this
i'm doing epic builds i'm doing builds
all right hey true it's true it's true
why is that a thing why can you launch
someone out of the map
has anybody just been launched outside
the map before chris hold up hold up
hold up chris if you don't mind we're
having an epic build off
oh shoot i lost tiger
oh kazinga get out of here
hey chris oh i just killed chris i was
getting shot by a guy with a light
machine gun i'm stuck in the pool
honestly are we sure fortnite isn't a
clone of this game yeah no i've actually
heard
mr fornate himself said he got inspired
by strucit
yeah get out of here you freaking nerd
back up yeah yeah don't ever try me like
that again carl
i'm sorry chandler i don't know how to
build at all like i cannot
good game good game good game jimmy got
five kills lol imagine getting a third
of the amount of kills that carl got
we're gonna have a bill battle everyone
have your ramps out what are we betting
what are we wagering
are you guys all okay with betting a
thousand dollars okay
yeah what are the rules okay here's the
deal boys galilei
10 ramp before you can shoot whoever
dies last gets him
ten eight nine wait you guys didn't
build up
ah i'm caging i'm kj i'm terrified chris
you're cheating
no i'm not cheating you have to get a
gun it's a thousand dollars bro i gotta
do
it i am building is anyone else building
or am i just taking it off
i think you're just taking it off ah
trailer died that doesn't count
bye jimmy
i just love when chris cheats it was
thirty dollars
hey man so i've never won a challenge is
all yeah
please don't rip a thousand dollars out
of my hands that was an investment chris
spent thirty dollars to make four grand
where yet carl come on face
me bro when do you want me on the bridge
oh is that you carl wait somebody's
shooting at him that's not me actually
whoever that is hey i did it i don't
know who i'm getting
shot by yeah and we didn't have 30 guns
all right that's fair i guess just
cheating to win no one else is up there
i know just kidding i was literally
standing behind carl sniping you and
that's it for this video
hit the subscribe button congratulations
on your four grand coral